name's maximum Barty and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about the Lombardi tails
[Music]
hey pal nice costume yeah I looked away
it's just you a face with a couple of
strings attached okay that's far enough
yeah it's a real piece so why don't you
just come along quietly that's to take
it just over there we can have a little
talk so the reason I'm here is stop that
it ain't going to work we've got plenty
of time to figure out what it was you
did and we got a fix for it so you can
just relax your college so you might as
well find out who by anyway the reason
I'm here is that I'm part of a group
what contains objects of people order of
an unusual nature yeah like yourself
suck the vu I know now you could try to
run but this gonna stop you before you
get too far
won't kill you but you'll get a love a
headache when you wake up this is drop a
horse and you will a hell of a lot less
than honest so I came here to find out
if the rumors were true and there really
was something near matching your
description we've shown you a couple
days ago but I figured we'd see you out
on the town tonight I was like Halloween
I could have any face I wanted you got a
face like mine you look forward to
wearing a mask so we sympathize only
tell me you get to come out and mingle
anyway we just been waiting for you to
come out where we kidnap you my
partner's watching us and pretty soon
we'll go for a ride in our van to your
new home need fare yeah I know they get
that a lot then you're right mate this
were an ideal world we could all live in
peace unfortunately you and me were born
in a cold bastard of a university
doesn't give a [ __ ] about fairness or
justice all we got is the best we can do
your MA I'm sorry kid we can't go back
to see her
I'll make sure to get some of the talk
to Assoc don't worry too much honestly
he's probably not going to remember a
whole lot of it it's one of the things
we do but we'll make sure she's okay
you got my word he'll tell you what we
bring you in we'll say you agreed on one
condition we get some cash to her make
sure she's nice and comfy for the rest
of her life the higher-ups will buy it
first lesson for you
skips will cooperate have life a hell of
a lot easier than the ones who fight
back they'll get what they want no
matter what but you could make things
easier on them they ain't stupid the
reward good behavior I can't let you go
kid you're in too deep
yeah you say you won't hurt anybody and
I believe you but we ain't the only ones
out here there's other folks in this
game only they don't want to keep you
contained they want to kill you a worse
turn you into a weapon they can make you
hurt people I've seen it done and
they'll hurt people to get to you people
like your mom she is a lot of threats
out there some of them are other people
some of them are things that would
destroy the world if we let them I see
what's out there and it ain't friendly
some of its wonderful some of them may
help us but some of it sincerely scares
the [ __ ] out of me and I don't scare
easy there are so many things out to get
us
someone's got to be out there as
humanity sight nobody's on your side
yeah but I'll tell you what you have any
real problems do you think you're being
treated too cruel
till you've got to get a word to maximum
body I don't got a lot of pull myself
but again maybe put a word near someone
who does I got a promise nothing
nobody's going to make everything right
you know we just do the best we can
[Music]